of the ukraine to participate in this
meeting it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules
i invite the following preachers to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
will now begin its consideration of item
2 of the agenda
i now give the floor
two miss rosemary de carlo
madam president
the war in ukraine is now in its third
week
fighting continues unabated
the russian armed forces are pursuing
their offensive operations and laying
siege to several cities in the south
east and north of the country
a large confrontation of russian forces
is reportedly masked along several
approaches to the capital kiev
the situation is particularly alarming
in mariupol keith sumi
and chernihief where there is shelling
of residential areas and civilian
infrastructure resulting in an
increasing number of civilians killed
and injured
the utter devastation being visited on
these cities is horrific
the numbers bear out the conclusion that
civilians are paying the highest price
for the conflict
as of 11 march
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights has recorded a total of 1
546 civilian casualties
including 564 killed and 982 injured
since the start of the invasion on 24
february
ohchr believes the real casualty figures
are likely considerably higher
as information from locations whose
intense hostilities are ongoing has been
delayed and reports are still pending
corroboration
most of the recorded civilian casualties
which include children
have been caused by explosive weapons
with a wide impact area including heavy
artillery and multi-launch rocket
systems and missile and airstrikes
ohchr
has received credible reports of russian
forces using cluster munitions including
in populated areas
indiscriminate attacks including those
using cluster munitions which are of the
nature to strike military objectives and
civilians or civilian objects without
distinction are prohibited under
international humanitarian law
direct attacks against civilians and
civilian objects as well as so-called
area bombardment in towns and villages
are also prohibited under international
law and may amount
to war crimes
as of 10 march the world health
organization has verified 26 attacks on
health facilities
health workers and ambulances
causing 12 deaths and 34
injuries this includes the bombing of
the mariupol maternity hospital on 9
march
we condemn such attacks without
reservation
they cause not only death and
destruction they also deprive people of
urgently needed care and endanger more
lives
we cannot emphasize it enough
the targeting of civilians of
residential buildings hospitals schools
kindergartens is inexcusable and
intolerable
all alleged violations of international
human law must be investigated and those
found responsible held accountable
madam president millions of people in
ukraine need urgent assistance
this includes two million internally
displaced people
we are scaling up humanitarian aid in
areas where security permits
more than half a million people are now
receiving assistance including
life-saving food shelter blankets and
medical supplies
the united nations and our partners have
developed operational plans to meet
humanitarian needs where they are most
acute
this work needs funding
over 1.5 billion dollars was pledged to
the appeals last week
we are grateful for this generosity and
encourage donors to release the funding
quickly madam president it is critical
to urgently achieve a secession of
hostilities to allow for the safe
passage of civilians from besieged areas
and to ensure that life-saving
humanitarian supplies can reach those
who remain
on 9 march over 51 000 people were
reportedly evacuated through 5 out of 6
agreed upon safe passages
these safe passages must continue
they should be implemented with clear
principles and modalities
civilians should be duly and timely
informed of the possibility
to leave the concerned areas and on a
voluntary basis and in the direction
they choose
to expand life-saving assistance and
services to those most in need
humanitarian actors must also have safe
rapid unimpeded and sustained access to
all areas
we commend the humanitarian actors on
the ground who are staying in delivering
in a highly volatile situation
madam president
the number of refugees from ukraine has
reached 2.5 million people
these numbers continue increasing by the
day
we also commend the countries that have
kept their borders open to welcome and
support refugees
all people fleeing ukraine including
third country nationals need access to
state safety and protection in line with
the principle of non-refund and without
any form of discrimination
madam president the need for
negotiations to stop the war in ukraine
could not be more urgent
we note the three rounds of talks held
thus far between ukrainian and russian
delegations
we call for such efforts to intensify
including to further secure humanitarian
and ceasefire arrangements as a matter
of priority
we urge the sides to build on their
contacts such as the meeting yesterday
between the foreign ministers of ukraine
and the russian federation in antalya
turkey
the logic of dialogue and diplomacy must
prevail over the logic of war
the secretary general is grateful to the
many member states working in pursuit of
a diplomatic solution to this dangerous
conflict
he is in regular contact with regional
and other leaders and his good offices
remain available
madam president
let me affirm the u.s commitment to
ukraine's sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
as the war grinds on
there's already much with reflection
about its implications
beyond the tragedy it represents for
ukraine
we increasingly hear the use of terms
such as turning point defining moment
end of multilateralism
i believe this is not an exaggeration
indeed some consequences are already
being felt economically and politically
perhaps most alarming of the risks the
violence poses to the global framework
for peace and security
we must do everything we can to find a
solution
and put an end to this war
and we must do it now thank you madam
president
i just
thank you madam president
madam president
distinguished members of the security
council
i thank council members for the
opportunity to brief you this morning
i am aware of reports that certain
public health facilities
are in areas impacted by armed conflict
putting the safety of those facilities
at risk
i appeal to all parties in this conflict
to ensure the safety of all such
facilities in ukraine
i am aware of media reports regarding
allegations of biological weapons
programs
the united nations is not aware of any
biological weapons programs
that is largely thanks to the 1972
biological weapons convention
which prohibits the development
production acquisition transfer
stockpiling and use of biological and
toxin weapons
the russian federation and ukraine are
both states parties to the convention
in addition the russian federation is a
depository government under the
convention
all states parties to the convention
have undertaken
never in any circumstances to develop
produce stockpile or otherwise acquire
or retain biological weapons
biological weapons have been outlawed
since the bwc entered into force in
1975.
a total of
183 states have now joined the
convention and biological weapons are
universally seen as being abhorrent and
illegitimate
the bwc lacks a multinational
verification mechanism overseen by an
independent organization
such as the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons
therefore
assessing compliance with its
obligations is a task for its state's
parties
madam president
despite the lack of an international
verification regime
the biological weapons convention does
however contain several measures
to which concerned states parties can
have recourse
in order to address situations in which
states parties have concerns or
suspicions about the activities of their
peers
for example
article 5 of the convention states that
and i quote the state's party studies
convention undertake to consult one
another
and to cooperate in solving any problems
which may arise in relation to the
objective of or in the application of
the provisions of this convention
and of course within the framework of
article 5
states parties have established an
annual exchange of information
based upon the submission of confidence
building measures
states parties must declare information
about relevant facilities and activities
on their territory in order to prevent
or reduce the occurrence of ambiguous
doubts and suspicions between them
the russian federation and ukraine
both participate annually in the
confidence building measures
the annual reports submitted by the
russian federation and ukraine are
available to all bwc states parties for
the purposes of transparency and
reassurance
in addition and also within the
framework of article 5 of the convention
states parties have developed procedures
for clarifying ambiguous and unresolved
matters
including the possible convening of a
formal consultative meeting to consider
such matters
article 6 of the convention states that
and i quote any state party to this
convention which finds that any other
state party is acting in breach of
obligations deriving from the provisions
of the convention
may launch a complaint with the security
council
if agreed by the security council an
investigation on the basis of the
compliance complaint received could be
initiated
article 6 of the convention has never
been activated
while these provisions have not been
regularly used they are nonetheless
internationally agreed procedures that
are available to be used to diffuse
tensions and to address and resolve any
concerns relating to
compliance with obligations under the
bwc in a multinational setting
i would therefore encourage bwc states
parties to consider make making use of
the available procedures for
consultation and cooperation
in order to resolve these issues
madam president
distinguished members of the security
council
situations such as this demonstrate the
need to strengthen the bwc
to operationalize it and to
institutionalize it
i would therefore like to take this
opportunity to encourage its state's
parties
to come to the convention's ninth review
conference
scheduled to take place in geneva later
in 2022
committed to a series of overhaul of the
convention to ensure it is properly
equipped and resourced to deal with the
challenges ahead
madam president distinguished members of
the security council
to conclude my statement i would like to
take this opportunity to address the
warring issue of the safety and security
of nuclear power plants in ukraine
an accident involving nuclear facilities
in ukraine could have severe
consequences for public health and
environment and all steps must be taken
to avoid it
the possibility of an accident caused by
failure to a reactor's power supply
or the inability to provide regular
maintenance is growing by the day
the forces in effective control of
nuclear power plants in ukraine must
ensure their safe and secure operation
i am extremely concerned that four of
the international atomic energy agency
iaeas
seven pillars of the safe and secure
operations of facilities are reportedly
not being implemented
at chernobyl and theriposia
communications must be fully restored
and operating staff must be allowed to
properly carry out their duties and to
do so
free of undue
pressure i would like to echo the sector
general support for iaea director
general gross's efforts
to develop a framework to ensure the
safety and security of ukraine's
facilities
and welcome the constructive meetings he
held in turkey
on 10th of march
with the foreign ministers of ukraine
and the russian federation i thank you
very much for your attention
i now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements i
give the floor to the representative of
the russian federation
is
a huge number of human lives
those
unfortunately
russia is
with support by the united states
ministry of defence
using synthetic biology
minister of defence
ukrainian science anti-plague institute
named after mexico and located in odessa
conducted by research centers in other
cities of ukraine in kiev and both in
hardcover
medical research
infectious diseases
into the walter reed army institute of
research
into the labor medical research of the
u.s navy and into the usr army
biological warfare laboratories in fort
des moines
which used to be
being the key facilities of the american
program to develop biological weapons
all of these materials are available on
the website of our ministry of defense
and our ministry of defense is uh
describing them in the course of their
daily briefings
let me just dwell on the more salient
examples
aware of the details of the project
infections using migratory birds this
includes
as well as in the newcastle disease
there was another project
[Music]
[Music]
because they do not give you an
opportunity to control how the situation
is
agents were conducted in the 1940s by
the infamous
squad 731 of the japanese army whose
members by the way filed refuge in the
united states and escaped justice
and many of them go through russia and
eastern europe
research i just mentioned
and in immediate proximity of the
russian border
to poland
of the russian federation
is going to be the fact that there was
no international control there and they
would just simply
will simply dissolve quite probably over
europe
in any event there's a very high risk
that they will be stolen and used for
terrorist purposes or for to
that they will be sold on the black
market
uh
[Music]
most of them almost slavic extra
extraction
because in theory bio agents can be
created which can selectively target
specific ethnic groups
at the same time the activity of
political laboratories
in ukraine uh when it comes to
particularly dangerous and economically
important infections
there is a growing number of german
measles um um cases diphtheria and
tuberculosis
village was born
went up by a factor of more than 100.
with a high risk of a an outbreak of
polio myelitis
there's also evidence to show
and 200 more were hospitalized
african swine fever in ukraine have
become irregular
break over disease which symptomatically
is very close to the plague
in the united states
we moved
into an experimental platform and using
their citizens as guinea pigs
these experiments were the potential
risks for the entire country is
something that we want to do for years
and we can see in this yet another
confirmation of an extraordinary
cynicism
mentors who tell us all the time that
they're very concerned by the fate of
the ukrainians
eliminated
particularly
dangerous
otherwise this could lead to the spread
of diseases amongst the population and
we don't know whether kiev implemented
that recommendation
under the leadership of specialists over
the united states who had diplomatic
immunities
apparently according to the defense
according to their request of their
western inventors are trying to clean it
all up to make sure that the russian
side does not find direct evidence that
the united states and ukraine are
violating article one of biological and
toxic weapons
biological programs
laboratories
with tularemia 10 with brucellosis
with plague overall 320 containers
it leads us to believe that these work
were conducted within the framework of a
military biological
nebula
i would like to address my colleagues
from europe
right next to you
you've had an experimental platform for
extremely dangerous biological trials
about a very real biological danger the
people in europe
uncontrolled spread of bio agents from
ukraine which as we have seen with covet
19 is impossible
and if there is such a scenario then all
right
representatives of the united states
[Music]
studies being conducted
there was a direct question put by
senator
and she replied and said
that
in ukraine
research structures which should not end
up in the hands of the russian armed
forces end of quote
of ukraine are there no um laboratories
under the control of the united states
agreement of 2005 between your ministers
technologies and pathogens which could
be used so as to develop bio weapons
in the area of joint
research determining the threats from
the biological agency and
working out the response to them as
relates to and i quote
into the dangerous pathogens
deployed on objects on the territory of
ukraine
[Music]
and also on the perimeter of the former
uh
about creating an effective verification
mechanism to ensure compliance
and this can lead us to the thought that
the united states have something to hide
call upon colleagues in these regions to
think about what kind of an activity
washington is conducting on their
territory what the consequences for your
people will be
see what the reaction will be from our
western colleagues who i'm sure are
going to be saying now that all of this
information is fake and russian
preparations
and i do not think this will be helpful
to the european people
in case there are outbreaks in ukraine
or neighboring states with further
spread awake dangerous diseases
the risk of this is very real
radical nationalist groups in ukraine
work with dangerous pathogens conducted
together with the ministry of defense of
the united
[Music]
say that they are striking against
scientific and medical institutions and
to or or link these incidents with the
russian diversionary groups
of worship
news analyzing the biological situation
in ukraine and the materials we keep
seeing
we told you today
is a very small partial portion of the
information
is something that we will disseminate in
the very near future as an official
document of security council you will be
able to stay so
we think it is our duty to keep the
security council
on the situation when it comes to the
military biological activity by the
united states in ukraine it creates real
risk for international peace and
security and we intend to revert to the
discussion of this topic in the very
near future
we do not exclude the possibility of uh
invoking the mechanism of articles five
and six of the biological women's
convention
at present however we expect to hear
responses from the american side to the
questions that we put
i thank you madam
i would like to thank the representative
of the russian federation and are you
the florida representative
of albania
thank you madame president
let me thank you as gdcarlo and usgina
commission for their information
i would like to make the following
points
first we meet at the request of russia
following allegations on a possible
program of development of biological
weapons in ukraine
we listen to their statement very
carefully
madam president
any issue regarding weapons of mass
destruction should never be taken
lightly
as we just heard from the usg the united
nations is not aware of any of the
alleged programming consistent with
international treaty obligations
including on chemical or biological
weapons
we heard about health facilities in
ukraine
we have heard repeatedly also a firm
rebuttal at the highest levels from both
the u.s and ukraine
therefore russia's allegations are in
our opinion
part of the information warfare false
unsubstantiated part of the usual
propaganda and the disinformation coming
from russia
conspiracy theories not worth our time
the council should be served
should not be served with fantasies or
story-eyed stories but with proof
independently verified and corroborated
this is not the
case however regrettable all this is it
is hardly surprising since everything
absolutely everything we have been
hearing from russia regarding ukraine
has been false fabricated or distorted
these are all in the public space
and do not deserve mentioning but the
real palm door goes to the russian
declaration just two days ago according
to which russia has not attacked ukraine
well as we saw last week the u.n general
assembly has a different account
in every other situation everyone would
have thought that this is a joke except
for the fact that this joke
is destroying a country
is killing civilians and is responsible
for more than 2.5 million refugees and
counting
that translates to 7 000 people per hour
reportedly this is also responsible for
the death of several thousand russian
soldiers but this is an issue for russia
and its people
all the more reasons
for the immediate cease-fire and leave
place to negotiations
second madam president
russia has a long and well documented
track record of using chemical weapons
including in attempts as in attempted
assassinations and in poisoning its own
citizens like the jailed opposition
leader alex navalny or the scripples
belling cut reporting has been
brilliantly able to make it derank a
direct and irrefutable link of the
attempted deadly poisoning with gru high
officials
we should therefore be very worried that
in spreading such disinformation a
crescendo of allegations about weapons
of mass destruction could serve
as yet another pretext for russia to
prepare the ground and use chemical or
biological weapons during its in-going
invasion of ukraine while accusing
others
after all russia has accused ukraine of
genocide in donbass which is ridiculous
it has also accused cave of seeking to
produce nuclear weapons which is
outrageous
it has accused ukraine of bombarding its
own cities which is preposterous
as we have heard many times including
yesterday russia has and continues to
support the regime of bashar al-assad in
syria which has used chemical weapons
against the civilian population
dear colleagues
we should retain our what should retain
our attention and deserves our time is
the escalating situation that is
wrecking two countries
threatening a whole continent and
disrupting the entire world
fifteen days into this brutal invasion
and the growing ormond might of russia
with the open complicity of belarus
has stalled before the steel-clad and
indisputable right of a nation to defend
its land
russia's goals are as abhorrent as the
means it is using to achieve them
we are horrified by the catastrophic
situation in mario paul another besieged
cities where civilians are starved
by the use of cluster ammunition
and in urban areas as we heard during
the briefing
by the redoubling of blind shelling and
bombardments
by more than 26 assaults on various
health related facilities or
including ambulances
as confirmed by the who and confirmed
during this meeting
by outrageous and immoral acts which
constitute war crimes
these are facts
nothing seems to be going as planned in
ukraine
the unprovoked unjustified and
premeditated act of aggression by russia
again with the complicity of belarus
lacks any legal or moral ground the very
ones that in turn empower ukrainians to
fight heroically
be ready to die for the ideals they
believe in for the right to choose who
they want to be to be shapers of their
own destiny
in this respect we welcome the
conclusions of the european council
which among others welcomed the will of
ukraine to join the european union
we are warm-hearted by the ukrainian
resistance
incomprehensible maybe to the invader
and which should be seen as an
inspiration and a reminder that freedom
always prevails over tyranny
let's not forget colleagues if russia
makes its way into ukraine it will not
stop there it will want more
and
as history reminds us aggression works
like a drug
this is why david must and
thank you mr president
and thank you to our briefers for your
remarks this morning
russia asked the security council for
today's meeting for the sole purpose
of lying and spreading disinformation
and that is exactly what you have heard
from the russian pr this morning
you also heard from miss
nakamisu
that the un is not aware of any
biological or chemical weapons programs
in ukraine
last month secretary blinken laid out
with tragic accuracy what russia was
about to do
he specifically warned that russia would
manufacture a pretext for attack
and even cautioned
that russia would fabricate allegations
about chemical or biological weapons to
justify its own violent attacks against
the ukrainian people
today the world is watching russia do
exactly what we warned it would
russia is attempting to use the security
council to legitimize disinformation and
deceive people to justify president
putin's war of choice against the
ukrainian people
and china too has been spreading
disinformation in support of russia's
outrageous claims
i will say this once
ukraine does not have a biological
weapons program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories supported by the
united states
not near russia's border or anywhere
so here are the facts
ukraine owns and operates its own public
health laboratory infrastructure
these facilities make it possible to
detect and diagnose diseases like covet
19
which benefit us all
the united states has assisted ukraine
to do this safely and securely
this is work that has been done proudly
clearly and out in the open
this work has everything to do with
protecting the health of people it has
absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing to do with biological
weapons
in fact it is russia that has long
maintained a biological weapon program
in violation of international law
it is russia that has weld a
well-documented history of using
chemical weapons
it is russia who is the aggressor here
it was russia russian operatives who
poisoned alexey navalny and sergey and
yulia skripal with nerve agents it is
russia that continues to support the
assad regime in syria and shield it from
accountability when the u.n and the opcw
have confirmed that assad has repeatedly
used chemical weapons over the past
several years
and we're deeply concerned that russia's
calling for this meeting is a potential
false flag effort in action
exactly the kind we have been warning
about including from secretary blinken
here in the security council last month
russia has a track record of falsely
accusing other countries of the very
violations that russia itself is
perpetrating
and given that and consistent with our
previous statements we have serious
concerns that russia may be planning to
use chemical or biological agents
against the ukrainian people
the attempt intent behind these lies
seemed clear
and it is deeply troubling
we believe russia could use chemical or
biological agents for assassinations as
part of a staged or false flag incident
or to support tactical military
operations
from the beginning
our strategy to counter russia's tactics
has been to share what we know with the
world transparently and candidly we have
been right more than often more than
we'd like to
we're not going to let russia get away
with lying to the world are staining the
integrity of the security council by
using this forum as a venue for
legitimizing putin's violence
russia has attacked homes
schools orphanages and hospitals russia
has attacked civilian infrastructure
including water and sanitation
facilities their forces are laying
ukrainian cities under siege
hundreds of thousands of civilians now
don't have access to electricity for
heat or drinking water to stay alive
russia is the aggressive aggressor here
and despite russia's best efforts
the media and everyday ukrainians are
documenting this truth on the ground
russia can't paint over the front page
of the new york times which on monday
featured the bodies of a ukrainian
mother and her two children who died
while trying to cross a bridge outside
kiev in their attempt to flee to safety
russia cannot cover up the work of ap
news reporters who captured a doctor
attempting
to resuscitate an 18 month old kirill
who died from russian shelling in maripo
russia cannot suppress the social media
posts confirmed and amplified by cbs
news that told the story of the 11 year
old ukrainian boy who fled to slovakia
by himself
with only a passport a plastic bag and a
phone number scrawled on his hands
russia cannot silence the al jazeera
report of russian soldiers terrorizing
ukrainian cities
and ukrainian journalists are risking
their lives every day to deliver to the
world the latest on the ground facts
such as novo vrimney
reporting on the reckless behavior of
russian forces toward
ukraine's nuclear facilities
russia is failing in his quest to create
an alternative reality in fact not even
russian diplomats can keep their
propaganda straight
just yesterday the kremlin spokesman
said he didn't have clear information
about the russian forces who fired on a
maternity hospital
then the foreign minister himself denied
russia attacked ukraine at all
right before admitting that russia
deliberately
targeted this maternity hospital in
maripool
their fabrications didn't matter because
the world had already seen the searing
images broadcast on cnn of bloodied
pregnant women being evacuated from the
scene of russia's attack on the hospital
even russian
russia's own citizens are tiring of such
lies
russian athletes are writing no war on
their shoes and on tv tv cameras
russian citizens are marching in the
streets and protesting putin's war of
choice
and even russian state tv pundits
putin's own propaganda arm have called
for putin to stop the military action
this is why we didn't object to holding
today's meeting today's meeting has
confirmed our predictions reveal
russia's objectives to the world and
expose russia's lies for what they are a
malicious effort to cover for the
atrocities being committed by russia as
part of their illegal and unprovoked
attack on ukraine
it is a page directly out of the russian
playbook and it will not convince us one
bit
the world is watching photographic and
video evidence is mounting and you will
be held to account for your actions we
will not let atrocities slide
unlike the russian government whose
first instinct is to silence
we are confident
that truth and transparency will prevail
we call on president putin to end this
unprovoked unconscionable war against
the ukrainian people thank you
[Music]
mr president
laboratories
is
along with 46 other states parties
orchestrated by somebody
else's weapons are banned
is
[Music]
is
against the war in russia
of the united kingdom
thank you mr president
russia has today
brought into the security council
a series of wild
completely baseless
and irresponsible conspiracy theories
let me put it diplomatically
they are utter nonsense
there is not a shred of credible
evidence
that ukraine has a biological weapons
program
ukraine is a state party to the
biological and toxin weapons convention
in good standing
as we've heard
the research facilities
are established facilities
set up to deal with public health
hazards
the un briefers today have confirmed
this
this is yet another lie in russia's
disinformation campaign
they said
they would not invade ukraine
they then invaded
foreign minister lavrov then said they
hadn't invaded
and he repeated this absurdity yesterday
a whole pack of
lies said ukraine was preparing a dirty
bomb
that was a lie too
they said yesterday that a pregnant
woman staged her injuries in the mario
paul hospital bombing
that was a grotesque lie
russia is sinking to new depths today
but this council must not get dragged
down with it
so let's get back to the facts
russia is invading ukraine in violation
of international law
russia is killing hundreds of civilians
through indiscriminate shelling of
ukrainian cities
it is using cluster munitions
and thermobaric rockets
weapons designed to inflict maximum
damage
wherever they are deployed
it is targeting hospitals and schools
and committing war crimes
thousands of russian and ukrainian
soldiers are dead
deaths
that will shatter the lives of families
they've left behind
2.5 million ukrainians have become
refugees one million children forced to
flee from president putin's invasion
this
is a war of choice that russia needs to
end
colleagues
russia has broken its commitments under
the charter
but we must not let it subvert the
multilateral system itself
as the un said today
russia is now putting at threat
the global framework for peace and
security
the security council
is responsible for addressing many
serious conflicts
around the world
we have important work to do
we do not sit in this chamber to be an
audience for russia's domestic
propaganda
and we should not allow russia
to abuse its permanent seat
to spread disinformation and lies
and pervert the purpose of the security
council
let us resolve today
that this council
remains focused
on the real threats to international
peace and security
i thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her statement
i give the floor to the representative
of india
thank you mr president
i thank usg nakamitsu and usd de carlo
for their briefings
we have noted the recent statements by
states
and wider information regarding the
biological activities relating to
ukraine
in this context we would like to
underline the importance attached by
india to the biological and toxin
weapons convention btwc
as a key global and non-discriminatory
disarmament convention
prohibiting an entire category of
weapons of mass destruction
it is important to ensure full and
effective implementation of the btwc
in letter and spirit
we also believe that any matters
relating to obligations under the btwc
should be addressed as per the
provisions of the convention and through
consultation and cooperation between the
parties concerned
mr president we have repeatedly
expressed serious concern over the
ongoing situation in ukraine
we sincerely hope that the ongoing
direct negotiations between russia and
ukraine would lead to secession of
hostilities
there is no other alternative
except the path of diplomacy and
dialogue
the dire humanitarian situation needs
immediate and urgent attention
we once again call upon member states to
adhere to the principles of the u.n
charter and international law and
respect the sovereignty and integrity of
states i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of india for
his statement
i now give the floor
organizations
the united nations
is
of
is
i now give the floor to the
representative of ghana
thank you very much mr president and let
me begin by thanking the high
representative for disarmament affairs
isuzumi nakamichu
and the usg for political and peacebuild
affairs rosemary dicarlo for their
briefings to the council this morning
i also welcome the participation in this
meeting of the representative of ukraine
mr president ghana has taken due and
careful note of the briefings
and the remark of the remarks of
delegations that are spoken before us
we believe that on account of the
information before as a determination of
ukraine's biological programs can only
be made
after further assessment by relevant
institutions
such as a world health organization to
establish the situation of the
biological laboratories under
concentration
and the state of infectious disease
research that we're being undertaken
therein
it is in this regard that we urge the
parties to respect the call for an
unconditional immediate ceasefire
and for the russian federation to
withdraw all of its invading troops from
the internationally recognized borders
of ukraine bearing in mind the
incalculable consequences that an
accidental
or deliberate release of chemical
biological agents in the conflict
theater
could have on the populations in and
around ukraine
but also on global stability and an
already fragile security environment
the reporterization of chemical and
biological agents in the war ukraine or
anywhere else
would be wrong
and that should not even be contemplated
as a state party to the biological
workplace convention
we believe that the call for a
verification regime for the bwc
continues to be valid
and that such an additional protocol
could be done in a manner that is
reasonable and sensible
especially in light of recent global
development including the coveted 19
pandemic
ghana remains deeply concerned about the
escalation of military bombardments in
several cities
of ukraine
which have given rise to a rapidly
deteriorating humanitarian situation
described by many as the west in europe
since the end of the second world war
we are also concerned by the
transmission of shocks of the war in
ukraine within the global economy
and the disproportionate impact that
developing countries and small economies
are having to bear on account of this
war
many of whom are already in the truth of
the covet 19 pandemic
and contend with the depths of several
thousands from the socio-economic
consequences
of
the pandemic beyond the scope of global
attention
international solidarity is therefore
important even as we maintain global
cohesion and stability
we remind the warring parties of the
obligation to respect and comply with
their commitments under international
law
international humanitarian law
and human rights law
in particular we call for the protection
of civilians and humanitarian workers in
ukraine
in accordance with the provisions of the
fourth geneva convention of 1949
relative to the protection of civilian
persons
in a time of war
mr president in concluding let me recall
ghana's long-held view that the
possession of proliferation of weapons
of mass destruction
including chemical and biological
weapons neither assures international
peace
nor national security
we all therefore have a responsibility
to ensure that we eliminate such weapons
from the present civilization we are
seeking to build i thank you very much
for your kind attention
i thank the representative of ghana for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of ireland
thank you very much mr president and i'd
like to thank the high representative
nakamitsu and under secretary john de
carlo for their
sober briefings this morning
mr president ireland deeply regrets the
decision of the russian federation to
call for today's
meeting
it has done so for no other reason than
to advance baseless claims against
ukraine and the united states
ireland has a long-standing and clear
policy on biological chemical and other
weapons of mass destruction
it is intolerable that russia as part of
its attempts to excuse its unjustifiable
and unlawful aggression against ukraine
is making
unsubstantiated and unfounded claims
against ukraine
regarding the alleged development and
possible use of biological and chemical
weapons
the prohibitions on biological
and chemical weapons must not be
undermined
given the reckless disregard for nuclear
safety and security shown by russian
forces since the start of the invasion
there are fears for cbrn safety arising
from the invasion
this in no way however supports the
claims of weapons of mass destruction
development in ukraine
we are familiar with this approach by
the russian federation
it forms part of a long-standing pattern
by the russian federation to use
disinformation and multiple multilateral
fora to distract deny and cover up its
own transgressions and aggressions
ireland considers it unacceptable
to levy such accusations against ukraine
a state party in good standing to the
treaty of the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons
the chemical weapons convention and the
biological weapons convention
these instruments are doing their vital
job of ensuring non-proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction and no
evidence has been advanced to support
such allegations in these fora
earlier this week 48 states including
ireland challenged these unsubstantiated
claims by russia in the opcw
i urge the russian federation to cease
its campaign of disinformation and not
to use this council as a platform to
spread disinformation
such harmful actions demean this body
and its role in maintaining
international peace and security
mr president the russian federation's
invasion of ukraine has created a
humanitarian catastrophe
in another effort to mislead and
misinform we've been told by the russian
federation that the humanitarian crisis
we are seeing in ukraine is not a result
of its actions
however as u.n briefers confirmed again
today it is clear that the russian
offensive is causing the suffering of
millions resulting in a rapidly rising
toll of internally displaced persons and
refugees in need of humanitarian
assistance
millions of people in ukraine are
struggling with the humanitarian
consequences of this senseless
aggression
whatever is agreed or not agreed on
humanitarian safe passage civilians and
civilian infrastructure must be
protected
compliance with international
humanitarian law is not optional
it is an obligation
full
safe and unhindered access to provide
humanitarian assistance is urgently
needed
mr president
one more time ireland urges the russian
federation to immediately cease
hostilities
unconditionally withdraw from the entire
territory of ukraine
and refrain from further threat or use
of force of any kind
against ukraine
it is beyond time to choose dialogue and
diplomacy as the only pathway to resolve
this conflict
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement i give the floor to
norway
thank you president
and i thank usg di carlo
and our representative nakamitsu for
their statements
two weeks ago the russian federation
in blatant violation of international
law
chose to wage an old drug war against
its peaceful neighbor ukraine
we reiterate our condemnation of these
acts of aggression
a few days later
russia misused its veto to prevent the
security council for for fulfilling its
mandate to maintain international peace
and security
and today
russia has called for a meeting based on
an uncorroborated narrative insinuating
that ukraine is developing biological
weapons
this impacts the credibility of this
council
let us not not forget the real threat to
international peace and security that we
are witnessing
an illegal war waged by the russian
federation against another sovereign
u.n member state
and we condemn the use of cluster
munition by the russian federation
confirmed here today
the russian invasion was preceded by
fabricated claims and unfounded
allegations
and it is intolerable that russia now
makes the unsubstantiated claim that
ukraine was preparing aggressive action
with the use of biological weapon
similar allegations have also emerged
when it comes to chemical weapons
production
as we heard from the u.n briefers
it is they are not available
that ukraine has developed or planned to
use either chemical or biological
weapons
president
norway remains a stone supporter of the
biological weapons convention
which remains one of the pillars of
disarmament
and the non-proliferation
of weapons of mass destruction
together with the non-proliferation
treaty and chemical weapons convention
and we condemn any use of such weapons
which
would constitute a clear violation of
these conventions
the convention have established a total
ban on chemical and biological weapons
all states parties were obliged to
destroy their stocks or such weapons
when they entered into these two
agreements
universal adherence and full
implementation by all state parties are
key
and i would like to remind that russia
must as a party to both conventions
uphold their international obligation
just like all states parties must
chemical and biological weapons cannot
and must not be used in war
president
i'm deeply concerned by the growing
humanitarian crisis in ukraine
and we are appalled by the blatant lack
of respect for international
humanitarian law displayed by the
russian military forces
in particular the blatant disregard for
their obligation to protect the
ukrainian civilian population
every day we see numerous reports of
russian shelling of homes school
hospitals and other critical civilian
infrastructure
this is unacceptable and must stop
the horrifying reports from this week's
attack on a medical facility in mariopol
are yet another example of the
disrespect for international
humanitarian law
the space for humanitarian action must
be restored and it must be protected in
a way that ensures continuous and
sustain humanitarian access
russia must end this war now we need a
withdrawal of all forces
and engagement in good faith throughout
a political solution
diplomatic solution must prevail
thank you
i would like to sign the representative
and give the floor to china
[Music]
rapidly evolving with growing complexity
and sensitivity
what is most needed now
continues to be to intensify diplomatic
efforts reduce tension
and bring the ukrainian issue back to
the track of a political settlement as
soon as possible
while making efforts to prevent a
massive large-scale humanitarian crisis
stop fighting and hostilities is a
widespread desire of the international
community
peace negotiations are the only viable
means to achieve that goal
recently
russia and ukraine have held multiple
rounds of derivatives
and the two foreign ministers held a
high-level meeting yesterday
all these are positive steps towards
achieving peace
the international community should
continue to encourage and support
russia and ukraine in their negotiations
in de-escalating the situation and
seeking peace
attaches great importance to bio safety
and security and consistently stands for
complete
prohibition and a thorough destruction
of all wmds including bio
logical weapons
firmly opposes the development
possession and the use of biological and
chemical weapons by any country and
under any circumstances
and encourage those countries that have
not yet
destroyed their
dog piles of chemical weapons to do so
as soon as possible
the purposes and principles of the
biological weapons convention should be
strictly upheld
logical weapons
weapons
mass destruction
any information and at least
military activities should trigger high
attention from the international
community china has noted with
concern relevant information released by
russia
i've held the biological weapons
convention it's an obligation for all
state parties the concerns raised by
russia should be properly addressed
china urges parties to effectively
implement their obligation under the
convention provide a comprehensive
clarification and accept
multilateral verification we have to
take a note of the press report that w
ho has advised to the ukrainian
government to destroy the pathogens
located in those labs in order to
prevent the spread of infectious
diseases
we look forward to be receiving more
specific information on this under the
current situation
of public health we call for ensuring
the safety and security of relevant
laboratories
mr president
the u.s representative in her statement
made
a groundless
the international community have been
raising concerns about the us military
biological activities
they
bcw the us said they are for
transparency
so that the international community
community can draw a conclusion by
itself thank you mr president
i would like to thank you representative
of china for his statement and give the
floor to brazil
thank you mr president
mr president
biological weapons were the first
category of weapon of mass destructions
to be subject to a comprehensive
prohibition
the biologic the biological weapons
convention
bwc adopted in 1972
binds all state parties to the
obligation to
and i quote
never in any circumstances to develop
produce stockpile or otherwise acquire
such weapons
and of course
brazil
believes
that any accusations
regarding violations of the basic
prohibitions set out by the bwc are
extremely serious
and as such
must be thoroughly substantiated by
solid evidence
such evidence must be presented
through and confirmed by an independent
and impartial authority s-4c in article
4 of the biological weapons convention
it is unfortunate
that such investigation mechanisms are
not strong enough at the moment
brazil also believes that legitimate
scientific and technological research on
biosafety and biosecurity
should be kept distinct and separate
from possible violations of the
prohibition
against the development and production
of biological weapons if
we wish to preserve the bwc regime
research into new and
dangerous pathogens
should be subject to strict transparency
mechanisms
brazil has long favored
the negotiation of a multilateral
verification protocol as a complement to
the
the
to the pwc
with additional measures to guarantee
protection and security against emerging
biological threats
the situation before the council today
only reinforces the urgency and the
necessity of such a mechanism
brazil strongly condemns the use or
threat of use of weapons of mass
destruction
including biological and chemical
weapons
anywhere by anyone under any
circumstances
i thank you
representative of brazil for his
statement and give the floor to the
representative of kenya
thank you mr president
i thank usg mary dicarlo
and representative nakamitsu for
their briefings and i welcome the
participation of the representative of
ukraine
the conflict in ukraine
continues at an acceptable cost to the
people of ukraine
and increasingly
to the entire world
as the prices of essential commodities
rise
sharply
our hearts go to the families who have
lost loved ones
as well as the millions of refugees and
internally displaced persons
we are also greatly concerned that the
armed conflict
has not spared objects indispensable to
the survival of civilian populations
including residential homes
health facilities as well as power and
water infrastructure
mr president
we have listened with deep concern
to the serious allegations
of the development
of biological weapons
in contravention
of the convention on the prohibition of
the development
production and stockpiling of biological
and toxin weapons
the security council
as mandated in the biological weapons
convention
is obliged to consider complaints
brought forward by any state party to
the convention against the breach of
this convention
the convention
weighs the security council with the
responsibility to consider
whether to carry out an investigation
should a state party formally launch a
complaint to trigger such a process
we must make the obvious observation
that there would need to be a halt to
the armed conflict to enable an
investigation
that mr president will then bring us to
precisely the same situation where we
are in today
even as ukraine and russia's diplomats
have just met in ontario to explore an
agreed basis for a ceasefire
we ask them to redouble their efforts
and to make use of the willingness of
many countries to lend their every
assistance to their talks
mr president
the risks of this conflict broadening
and escalating
should be taken with extreme seriousness
already its effects are being
experienced far outside ukraine
the sanctions and counter sanctions are
threatening the world food supply
and rapid energy price increases will
drive millions more people into poverty
even as they struggle to recover from
covets
impact
humanity is teetering on the edge of a
precipice
the coming economic shock
if a ceasefire is not imminently
announced
would be accompanied by political crisis
and more conflict situations
in regard to the serious allegations we
have had
whatever action is undertaken in the
security council
should be matched by a newfound
commitment
by all member states
to the biological weapons convention
we urge its 183 states parties to seize
the opportunity of the ninth review
conference later this year to strengthen
the biological weapons regime
and the norms that safeguard humanity
from the threat of use of these
abhorrent weapons
ultimately mr president the only way out
of this crisis is to pause the armed
conflict and give a chance to dialogue
to shape a stable european security
order in which the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all members is
protected
area farm kenya's recognition
of the sovereignty territorial integrity
and political independence of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders i thank you
um
the serious accuracy
is
absolutely in the boundary
in ukraine
on the prohibition
is
is
[Music]
the substance of the issue we put
forward
which according to which a guilty mind
is
[Music]
of
suffering suffering victims and
destruction
which then reverberated in the whole
region reverberated also in the form of
a terrorist organization called
[Music]
unaware of the military biological
programs in ukraine
which were raised to the ground
and i do
raised this issue many times but this
died and this died and was buried
atrocities of the russian army attacks
on hospitals kindergarten schools
maternity hospitals using cluster bombs
something that
that that was refuted repeatedly by our
ministry
the majority hospital number one
in marijuana has become
has become um the common parlance in
this regard
did you listen to what we said here in
this room on monday the 7th of march
when we said that the fight with the
radicals
converted to that building
into a
an attack base this is something that we
warned about even that but apparently
you don't listen or you don't hear what
it
is did you see the photos
the allegedly destroyed a maternity
hospital the building
was destroyed by a bomb you what you can
see in there it's a building without
windows but it's not destroyed here are
the
photos happened to a building if it
underwent a bomb
strike or a shelling as well as to those
who were inside them
so we have the videos from inside the
building here they are
can you imagine what kind of destruction
would have remained in the wake of a
building hit by a rocket or a bomb ask
military specialists they will tell you
they have already said that
they show the photos of a crater
near the building
which resulted from an exploded mine
about the 17 wounded in the building
and not a single death by the way to the
kazakhstan
evidence
ukrainian blogger mariana
is using two different kinds of makeup
to present herself as two different
women in in photographs and this is
something that that was revealed by the
network users
by the dirty campaign to blame us for
intentionally shelling a civilian
psychological operation
at the same time
in
silence over the fact that you have
basically shut off your access to
russian sources of information we found
a great deal of new
things these days about the freedom of
speech that you seem to champion i would
would like to react now
my uh uk colleague she quoted minnesota
in completely as usual
and it is true that the war was not
begun by us it started eight years ago
by the key of authorities
is
which apparently they used to arrive
there
a logo of the united nations
um
logo on a car which is used for military
activities is unacceptable
forward for further statement you have
the floor
i know that
i know that you expect me to respond
but we're not going to give any more
error time to the lies that you're
hearing today is beneath this council
and there's only one aggressor here and
that is russia and we hope they will be
able to find it in their conscience
to end the attacks and stop the
suffering of the ukrainian people thank
you
thank you representative of the united
states for her statement
of
ukraine
well thank you mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
madame under secretary general de carlo
madam under secretary general nakamitsu
i should also acknowledge the presence
of a separate category here
a representative of the aggressive state
who sits in the seat of the soviet union
in the security council
the status of which was recognized by
the general assembly resolution es 11
1 and that is the status of aggressive
state
there is already a long record of
russian lies established here in the
council
and only the recollection of the items
of lies over the last two weeks will
take perhaps uh
an hour or so
but let me mention just
a couple lowest of the lowest
and i would not hesitate to mention them
again after the
representative sitting in the soviet
seat i just said refer to them
let me quote his king kingpin
russian foreign minister lavrov
who said yesterday indeed
i quote we
do not plan to attack other countries we
did not attack ukraine either
end of court
an outlet of the russian lies the
russian embassy in london
tweeted yesterday that a pregnant woman
is
in the attack maternity hospital in
mariupol was wearing makeup and was
playing a multiple
was playing multiple roles of pregnant
women
and indeed
moscow
and the russian ambassador here are
struggling to get this story straight
kremlin spokesman
piskov told reuters
in the immediate aftermath aftermath of
this strike on wednesday that i quote
russian forces do not fire on civilian
targets end of quote
on thursday he told reporters that the
kremlin would look into the incident i
quote because you and i
don't have clear information about what
happened there end of quote
following a meeting with the ukrainian
foreign minister in turkey on thursday
russian foreign minister lavrov took a
different stance
as he claimed without evidence that the
hospital in mariupol was a warranted
target because the building had been
seized long ago by ukrainian armed
groups
let me
share with you a very good news
miss mariana the pregnant woman
gave birth to a healthy daughter last
night
her name
is veronica
here is she is with your father
no matter what
the russian lies
are
about yourself
her family
and the incident
mr president uh whatever the gentleman
in the soviet state may say in reply
is most probably
useless
we need to hear directly from the
mastermind of the war crimes committed
so far
as we established that he was out of
loop on many occasions
having no clue what was going on on the
ground
we know quite well that the manic
obsession with which putin fantasizes
about non-existent biological or
chemical weapons or hazards in ukraine
is very dangerous
it may actually point at russia
preparing another horrific false flag
operation
so what else are you going to use
against ukraine cruise missiles multiple
rocket launchers heavy aerial bombs
we have already experienced all of this
what is next
ammonia phosphorus
and what will be the next target
one more residential
building one more maternity hospital
one more school
or maybe one more cultural heritage site
russian troops have already hit all
these
sites all of them
by calling this meeting
the aggressive state
has shoot itself in foot once again
ukraine runs a health system that is
totally in full compliance with his
international obligations
and in in full cooperation with all
relevant international organizations
the rest is is bunch of insane delirium
of putin and his henchmen
including the russian mission to the
united nations
russia does not give a monkeys about
safety of its own citizens
including thousands of
decomposing bodies of russian soldiers
soldiers send by putin to ukraine
to this ongoing carnage
i regret that the security council is
being now manipulated
by the russian federation to promote
such an insane delirium
it is enough disregard by the russian
federation of the members of security
council
finally it is detrimental for the
council's credibility
what indeed has to be addressed by the
council are the war crimes and crimes
against humanity that the russian
federation commits on a daily basis
since 24th of february
the day when the war in europe unleashed
by russia started
among the most recent examples that
shocked the world
russian airstrike that destroyed the
maternity hospital that we already
mentioned so many times today
russian indiscriminate shellings and
airstrikes have almost destroyed
mariupol
one of the most beautiful cities
on the azov sea
and killed 1580
civilian residents of that city
according to the local administration
for the first time
since the world war ii people are being
buried in mass graves in ukrainian
cities
i would like to use this opportunity
to ask the gentleman in the soviet seat
if you are rarely connected wired to
moscow
please talk to moscow
to release the kidnapped mayor of the
city of melitopol
please help
us get him back from the arms of the
invaders
and many other ukrainian cities are
being raised to the ground
documents and maps ceased by the
ukrainian troops from russian prisoners
of ball confirmed that bombardments of
presidential areas had been planned in
advance
captured russian pilots at today's press
conference in kiev have reconfirmed that
they deliberately dropped the bombs on
residential areas
the number of civilians killed by the
russian troops exceeds military losses
many people have lost their homes more
than
1.5 million left ukraine almost 2
million by now
across the western border
hundreds of thousands if not millions
became idps
only from kharkiv 600 000 people were
evacuated by trains
the main efforts are now focused on
ensuring safe passage of civilians
through humanitarian corridors
unfortunately the arrangements are often
violated by the russian troops
awful pictures and footages taken near
the destroyed breach in european with
killed civilians including entire
families who tried to flee the occupied
areas have circled and clarified
the globe
russia must not use civilians as
hostages in human shield
by exposing cities
to indiscriminate shelling and creating
a dire humanitarian situation
deliberately shelling civilians during
the evacuation from the besieged
ukrainian cities russia is forcing
civilians to flee their homes and
providing only a corridor to its
territory or to belarus
so-called green corridors proposed by
the aggressor for sending people to
russia and belarus could be considered
as forcible deportation
of protected persons according to
international humanitarian law
mr president
ukrainian people are being killed and
ukrainian cities are being destroyed as
we are
compelled to listen to the russian
absurd fakes in the security council
fakes created in a desperate attempt
to whitewash
the war against ukraine
russian aggression threatens
us all and there is an urgent need to be
resolute
in
countering uncivilized barbaric and and
mean actions by russia
the sooner the aggressor is stopped and
hold accountable for his crimes the
safer
our world will be
i will not end
before i read several paragraphs
from an open letter from 194
nobel laureates
i quote
the under signed nobel laureates voice
our support
for the ukrainian people
and the free and independent state of
ukraine as it faces russian aggression
194 nobel laureates
in a move that recalls the infamous
attack of nazi germany
on poland in 1939
using similar tricks
of faint provocation
the government of the russian federation
led by president putin has launched an
unprovoked military aggression
nothing else but a war
against its neighbor ukraine
we choose our wars carefully here
who we do not believe the russian people
have a role in this aggression
we join in condemning these military
actions
and presidents putin's essential
incessant essential denial of the
legitimacy
of ukraine's existence
we respect
the calm
and the strengths of the ukrainian
people
we are with you
our hearts go out to the families and
friends of all ukrainians and russians
who have died and been injured already
may peace come to this piece of our
beautiful world
end of quote i thank you
ukrainian
i think the representative of ukraine
foreign
is
say go ahead
there we go
uh
they're coming over here
twisted
oh
oh
feeling look at that
oh
oh
yes
[Music]
i gotta listen to the
just quickly
you've heard what just went on in the
council and i just want to say
we believe in truth we believe in facts
we believe our eyes and our ears we
actually believe what you are reporting
every single day
we believe independent media we believe
the world is bearing witness to a war of
russian aggression and no matter how
much russia tries it can't change that
that's what today showed and it
continues to show that russia is the
aggressor here no one else thank you